Okay, let's have a look at these links.
This link click here is
obviously a problem.
Click here doesn't tell me anything
about what's going to happen
if I were to click it.
So that's the first one,
all of these add to order
links look a bit suspicious.
Add to order is an action but they're
at least styled to look like links.
If I were to pull up the dev tools,
I'll see that they're actually
implemented as buttons.
So those are fine.
Now this logo is also a link, but
once again if you open dev tools
you'll see that it has alt text.
So that's okay.
Now, if you were to tab through
the links you would see a problem.
It's skips over the navigation
links up at the top.
What's going on,
they're spans styled to look like links.
Clearly this is an over
engineered restaurant website
built like a single page web app.
So I'm going to check that one as well.